you can't say too much but what about
your perspective on it are you most
excited about people seeing there is a
new director I don't know if you know
this they're remaking the Wizard of Oz
which I cannot believe we had my my
cousins my niece and nephew over a
couple weeks ago we watched The Wizard
of Oz it's it's Perfection it's absolute
perfection do you guys even know this
that The Wizard of Oz is the first color
movie of all time so when the movie
began when you watch that opening of The
Wizard of Oz in black and white until
they get to Oz when it becomes color can
you imagine being in the movies what
year did that come out 19 1939 Brock
you're not even Googling that you just
know that up the top of your head Brock
1939 where's it can you imagine going to
the movie theater having only seen black
and white movies not that off of silent
films and then you go to the movie
theater in 1939 and then you're 15
minutes into a movie and then you see
color like just try to think how amazing
that is anyway it's it's Perfection it
should never be touched anyway of course
they are remaking uh The Wizard of Oz to
be a nonwhite Wizard of Oz they're also
remaking It's a Wonderful Life by the
same director her name is Kenya Baris
and uh you know she's just about had it
with you white people know you can't say
too much but what about your perspective
on it are you most excited about people
seeing and what I actually want to ask
about both of them both Wizard of Oz and
its Wonderful Life um Wizard of Oz for
me I you know it it happens I'm from
Englewood it happens from a girl who
lives in the bottoms which is which is
Darby Park which is a part of Inglewood
and it it takes place under she falls
into Inglewood and I it the original
Inglewood took the original Wizard R
took place during the Great Depression
and it was about self-reliance and what
people are going through I think this is
a perfect time to sort of like switch
with the characters and talk about what
someone imagines their life could be and
it's ultimately a hero's journey someone
thinks something is better than where
they're at and they go and and realize
that where they're at is where they
should be I want people to sort of be
proud and happy about where they're from
and but I want the world to take a look
at it um and I hope that would could
come through I think it's a wonderful
life I feel like Christmas movie is are
amazing and I think the idea of taking
something that has that long of a a
history and a tale behind it and putting
a amazing piece of talent you know to
tell that story I think you know it's a
guy who's trying to help out his
community and things going to turn
around on him and I think that's you
know a perfect story to tell for a
person of color black or brown to get
okay first off I guess I have to make a
correction there Kenya appears to be a
man I mean who am I to decide with
someone's genders but we had we did a
quick run through on the show this
morning so I guess that's a man but the
point is nobody needs remake these
things was The Wizard of Oz like if
you're if you think the Wizard of Oz
wasn't gay enough for you you are so gay
you should be studied by scientists
right like you don't think that the that
the Tin Man and the Scarecrow and the
and the uh the lion I mean these were
these people I don't know what they were
doing you know what I mean anyway what
Dei leads to is an endless decline in
everything our products will not be as
good because they will not be designed
by the best Engineers our our bridges
will not be as good our movies will not
be as good our our TV shows I think I've
mentioned to you once or twice I have a
friend who I cannot uh say her his or
her name but it's a chick a real chick
um but she is a legendary actress in
Hollywood a comedy actress many many
sitcoms over the years and uh she basic
I can't really say this it'll it'll give
it away too much anyway they've
destroyed everything in Hollywood can I
just leave it at
that